字幕提供
他除全席喔
他的表現喔
都沒有表現很好
我是這麼覺得啊
反正你各位記得喔
除全席呢
你可以做多也可以做空
但是
那種高股息的你要特別注意
不要去買他的股票參與除全席
因為高股息的股票
常常他的表現比較差
所以你要
你要買除全席之前呢
你可能要點一下
像東元
東元呢
之前呢
在除席當天的表現不太好
所以你要買這個股票除菸息呢
一定要特別避開
除菸當天表現不大好了
那你要買呢 就要找當天表現比較好的
那這些都有統計啦
所以各位你可以看一下統計的狀況
看他之前表現好不好
各位你要記得看這個
當日操作的報酬統計啊
這邊會有除菸的狀況
這邊會有一些星星啦
星星數越多會越好
群光各位看一下
都爛嘛 有沒有
他是一個高股息ETF喜歡的股票嘛一出息完就開始跌嘛這種呢蠻常見的在高股息的標定裡面常見
你假如你的股票是高股息
我建議你在除息前把它賣掉
然後呢你再看一下這個軟體
歷年來呢表現都很爛
例如群光歷年來表現都很爛
每次除息都下跌
那你就在它除息前把它賣掉
你把他賣掉
不要拆下除息啦
你拆下除息沒用啊
你拿到利息有用嗎
各位你看
141塊拿到利息還7塊
現在剩116
你把141塊把它賣掉
現在16買回來
差了25塊
等同於你配息25塊
還不用繳稅
所以高股息的標的呢
各位記得
高股息標的常常都有這種狀況
配完期之後
大家不碰了嘛
那個頭戲不買了
頭戲每次都這樣
他買股票
參與除選席是為了拿來配席的
他不是為了賺價差的好不好
我們都是想賺價差
那你假如你真的想要配席
你可以自己配給自己啊
你把錢
拿去放在你的期貨戶頭
現在呢 微台呢
你放45萬
算4萬5千點
4萬5千點 你放45萬
45萬買一口微台
然後呢 你要配席自己從裡面領
你大概可以配個10%嘛
這個按照期望來算配個10%沒什麼問題
好所以呢這個高股息齁
高股息各位
標的記得要篩選一下